what is the honest realistic total do
you think of Migrant workers have died
from as a result of what they're doing
for the World Cup in totality
well good evening for the World Cup uh
in Qatar welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored a competition that began in a
blaze of hypocritical sanctimony has
become what it always should have been a
feast of great football with
unpredictable results Unforgettable
drama and a billion eyeballs glued to
the biggest sporting event on the planet
that's how it should be for the past few
weeks it's been a uniquely negative
narrative about this world cup driven I
have to say mostly from England here in
Doha reality feels very different I've
been here for a few days now and found a
thriving Cosmopolitan Sportsman City and
a stunning vantage point for a
tournament played out in magnificent
purpose-built stadiums that are filling
up more with every game I gotta say the
conversation in Qatar is less about
rainbow bucketheads hats and arm pads
and more about the football why is
Gareth Southgate living Phil foden on
the bench could anyone stop killing
mbappe how badly injured his Neymar
could Ronaldo or Messi's last World Cups
end in the biggest trophy of all and of
course is it coming home spoiler alert
probably not from here in Qatar the
tournament Bears no resemblance to all
the doommongering headlines back home
fans from across the world are safe and
mingling happily the stadiums are not
selling beer those who want to drink
alcohol can do so all over the city
there's no sign of the shameful booze
fueled scenes of our own Euros final at
Wembley now of course Qatar is not
without fault women's rights and gay
rights are restricted by Western
standards migrant workers have
indispitably been treated badly
but those statements apply to many of
the countries around the world including
many competing in this tournament and by
many nations who've hosted major
sporting events without anything like
the furore that's kicked off about Qatar
we seem to have forgotten in England
that in 1966 when we hosted and won the
World Cup it was illegal to be gay in
our country
moral Halos appear to have slipped over
some people's eyes and escured some
rather Salient facts for example there's
12 of the population here are native
qataris something William these
supposedly sophisticated West would
never tolerate the migrants who come
here in vast numbers are sometimes
mistreated but the reason they're here
in the first place is because the wages
they earn are life-changing and the
global scrutiny of the World Cup has at
least led to reforms in labor laws here
that will be an important Legacy and one
massively lacking after two Olympic
Games in China and a World Cup in Russia
Qatar is also a significant investor in
many aspects of UK life for example it
gives us 25 percent of our gas
which is Food For Thought isn't it is
our national grid considers winter
blackouts with all the virtue signalers
back home prefer we tell Qatar to stop
sending its gas
this tournaments brought the football
mad Middle East together as well two
years ago Qatar was under a blockade led
by Saudi Arabia Bahrain and the UAE now
fans of most countries are pouring in to
enjoy the football saudi's Crown Prince
was at the opening ceremony the Emir of
Qatar even waved a Saudi flag during
their stunning win over Messi's
Argentina
there's no denying the Middle East has a
long way to go on human rights and many
social issues but so frankly to a lot of
European countries there's also no
denying that this region the Middle East
has long deserved its World Cup
and there's no denying and I can tell
you this is what most people here are
thinking that right now qatar's putting
on a pretty good show
and frankly when it comes to morality
are we in England really in any position
to lecture the Middle East about laws or
values given the way we illegally
invaded Iraq 20 years ago sparked in two
decades of Isis Terror and at last
year's Euros final showed the world that
we're a bunch of coke snorting boost
sodden brawling firework exploding from
backside imbeciles
me thinks not what is the honest
realistic total do you think of Migrant
workers who've died from as a result of
what they're doing for the World Cup in
totality
the estimate is around 400. before
between 400 and 500 are not I don't have
the exact number that's that's something
that's being discussed I mean there will
be people and Sony say that's a lot of
people
they would say 400 is a price too big to
pay what do you say to that what I will
say is
one death is a death too many plain and
simple
um and I think every year the health and
safety standards on the sites are
improving at least on our sites the
World Cup sites and ones that we're
responsible for most definitely to the
extent that you've got trade unions
representatives of the German Trade
union representatives of the Swiss
Traders just to make this point have
commended the work that's been done on
on the site on the World Cup side right
and improvements right but do you accept
them because of the improvements that
have been made that at the start they
weren't good enough
the standards I think overall the need
for labor reform in itself dictates that
yes improvements had to happen and just
so we're clear this was something that
was recognized before we bid the
improvements that have happened isn't
because of the World Cup these are
improvements that we knew we had to do
because of our own values improvements
that have to happen whether it's in
terms of health and safety standards
whether it's in terms of improving
accommodations as standards whether it's
in terms of dismantling the cafala
system now what the World Cup did the
World Cup served as a vehicle as an
accelerant as a catalyst and you know
because of the spotlight which we
recognized early on was going to be shed
it allowed you know it caused a lot of
these initiatives not only in terms of
improvement in the legislation but in
the enforcement of it as well and that's
where today you know where we led to you
know
we got to a position where
our most Ardent of critics consider us
today to be a benchmark
in the region good evening from London
it seems only yesterday I was in Qatar
it was only yesterday that was actually
at 2 A.M this morning so there we are
the wonders of modern travel welcome to
piersburg and sense that it's become
very fashionable recent years to smear
the British Monarchy as racist it's the
age of white privilege today's Royals
must atoned the colonial sins are out of
touch Beyond reform they should be
abolished and embark on an endless
groveling apology tour for the terrible
ancestors I find most of that complete
nonsense the monarchy is mostly a reason
for immense national pride they
represent us with distinction and
dignity to the world that's why when the
queen died the whole world stopped still
for 10 days to pay homage to her and
what she stood for
but there is a duty I think for everyone
at the Royal household from a top down
to be responsible about the positions
they hold and sometimes they let us down
last night Camilla the Queen the new
Queen hosted a reception on domestic
violence at Buckingham Palace well Lady
Susan Hussey Prince William's godmother
and was one of the Queen's closest Queen
Elizabeth's closest aides for many many
decades
made racially charged comments to the
head of a domestic abuse charity in
gozie Fulani the woman she spoke to
released a transcript of what she says
it's a conversation they had we've had
it voiced by producers
where are you from Sister space no where
do you come from We're based in Hackney
no what part of Africa are you from I
don't know they didn't leave any records
well you must know where you're from I
spent time in France where are you from
here UK no but what nationality are you
I'm born here and I'm British no but
where do you really come from where do
your people come from my people lady
what is this oh I can see I'm going to
have a challenge getting you to say
where you're from when did you first
come here lady I am a British national
my parents came here in the 50s when oh
I knew we'd get there in the end your
Caribbean no lady I'm of African
Heritage Caribbean descent and British
nationality
well let me be very clear those comments
in today's age I'm afraid are shocking
they crass they're offensive they're
racist
that's why Lady Hussey is now rightly
resigned the palace says the comments
are unacceptable they've quickly fronted
up to this Scandal for that they deserve
credit this won't go away in a hurry it
will be grace to the mill for those who
want to trash the monarchy and Brandi a
racist institution the timing could
hardly be worse next week the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex will be ludicrously
given a human rights award for fighting
racism in the royal family it was Megan
of course who infamously smeared the
monarchy as racist in her Oprah Winfrey
wineathon Megan has never produced any
evidence the conversation of he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
well Meg has ever given any hard
evidence to back up any of her racism
claims but mud sticks the damage was
done and this Scandal will undoubtedly
fuel those who think that there was
Merit to what she said
now what's been going on today by
coincidence is that Prince William and
the Princess of Wales have been in the
United States in Boston for a three-day
tour and that will now be completely
overshadowed by this new race storm back
in London I think that's why he took the
unusual step today of attacking lady
Hussey remember his own godmother
directly racism has no place in society
William spokesman said these comments
were unacceptable and it's right that
the individual stepped aside with
immediate effect that individual is his
own godmother
and make no mistake she wasn't a minor
background figure at the palace lady
Hussey was the late Queen's most loyal
lady and waiting for I think five or six
decades
she Stood Beside the new Queen Camilla
on state occasions and it will raise
uncomfortable questions about how
somebody in her position could possibly
be so stupid
after Megan's original baseless claims
Prince William said categorically
they're all family is not a racist
family and I believe him I also believe
the monarchy is a powerful unifying
force in our country but in this year of
transition with all eyes on King Charles
or the coronation coming and inevitable
questions about the future of the
monarchy has to do better than this
nobody capable of such witness and
offensive comments should be in the
Royal household this right lady Hussey
has gone
but there should also now be a fool I
think investigation to see if anybody
else in that household shares similar
sentiments and Views because if they do
they shouldn't be there alluded to the
fact that you had Suicidal Thoughts at
one stage yeah no serious yeah that's
serious I mean you talked about it I I
had a wonderful life
uh
uh fortunate lucky I played 17 years as
a footballer it was glorious best years
of my life
I'll give you that yeah okay okay and uh
and then went to what uh in the sport I
love for a new broadcaster it was about
to revolutionize football in the way it
did and had 20 years there
so I suddenly found myself at a really
dark place
the house surrounded by people
and I knew I had
done something wrong of course I did
but I couldn't compute it
and my head was gone and if I hadn't
been to my wife I don't know what would
happen I really don't Rachel is amazing
wonderful you really you were that low
yeah I was closely going down the garden
where I used to have a pool a pond down
at the Garden with a little bottle and a
few bowls I know it's I would have had
that
I was up at one day I was that bad yeah
but
I mean that's so horrific
people who normally will probably think
yeah your kitten because you two nobody
can see it in your face now even as you
read think about it again total it's a
very emotional thing to relive it
I couldn't work it out
and you had done wrong but I thought you
know for two weeks I couldn't get out of
the house
um we were just surrounded by pressing
TV cameras and Crews and uh
and your family was what saved you yeah
Rachel and the kids
and Pals
you know friends people who
you allowed to your friends have pierced
with things that happens to you and I I
think we both did them we both learned
did you know how how low Andy yes I was
there too same oh feeling suicide oh
peers really you have no idea it's it's
you know
mental health it
he's right you can't explain you look
back now with a clear head and a clean
you got what come on what are you
thinking you know but when you're in
that place and and he's right you
couldn't the only I used to have to
leave my house from the from my back
Garden I would walk to a local Nursery
that was close by I got a taxi and I
flew out here actually because uh NASA
Al khalifi who I'd worked for earlier
2008 and he wanted me to join then and
of course I should have done when I was
too comfortable I should have taken this
off if I didn't so he he called and said
look nobody's talking about it out here
why don't you come out here but then the
heat got too much and I felt I had to
back away for us because it was going to
bring too much attention to this country
and they didn't need to inherit our
problems at that time so so we put it on
a burner so in in effect I lost two jobs
in we lost two jobs in in two weeks
um one of them of our own volition but
no it's a it's I think it was wrong that
you lost your job
well I talked about how it made you feel
let me ask you can I ask you then can I
can I turn that on you yeah because I I
would like to know do you think it was
wrong we lost our jobs well it's
interesting you know when I've looked at
it all again it feels to me like an
overreaction by everybody because I
think that you you made fulsome
apologies I know Karen Brady for example
who is one of the bosses of West Ham and
when one of her players got caught
kicking a cat around horrendous video
came out she said everyone deserves a
second chance of forgiveness
and yet I remember her reaction to when
you two were sacked and it was a
different reaction and I felt there was
a real kind of
Feeding Frenzy to do you win yeah